Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcasts from Monday,
May 16th,
2016 how's it going?
How are you?
How's your life?
Are you liking your life?
Are you enjoying your life?
Do you hate your life?
Would you like to make a change?
Well,
fortunately there's a solution with my new seven part eight track tapes.
I'll help you turn around your life by making me a rich motherfucker first thing
you do.
Um,
anyways,
I am in a great fucking mode.
It's actually a Sunday when I'm recording this.
When I'm recording this.
It's Sunday.
And,
uh,
I got the fucking
shoes.
Yeah.
Juices are flowing.
Blood is flying through my system right now.
Heart grade,
fucking wonderful.
You know why?
Cause I worked out the last two fucking days in a row and my brand new gerage
Raj,
fuck it,
Jay.
Hello.
My New fucking gym.
It's finally done.
I went back and I picked up my,
uh,
my truck.
You know my old fucking Ford truck that I had a in storage while they finished
it.
They did a phenomenal fucking job.
I,
I'll fit it.
The whole thing with a bunch of rogue fitness shit.
And um,
I never fucking show you my house.
I might have to make a video.
I might have to show is a little fucking chips,
a little cute.
Cim.
I'll give you a before and after,
you know,
I might even wear my leg warmers for you.
I'll give you a quick two second tour.
The God damn thing.
I got my atomic holds up top and a,
I got to tell you,
all freckles,
old freckles lost a lot.
A lot of what little he had.
Holy Shit.
I went onto the pegboard.
I felt like,
you know,
the 40 only first time you ever tried to do a pull up in your life.
It's like this.
It was like you were born without those muscles because you never use them.
You know what I mean?
It's not like you go,
oh,
what's on top of the fridge?
You know,
what do you do?
You jump up and down,
usually cash.
You don't grab the top of it and fucking pull yourself up.
You little stupid feet squeaking on the front of the fucking weed as you try to
go up,
which is cheating by the way.
And if you ever made a video of it and you put it on Youtube,
I'm sure there would be hundreds of thousands of comments saying that it was an
epic fail refrigerator.
Uh,
pull up.
It's cause people like when you fail,
you know why?
Because they don't like themselves.
Um,
so it's done.
And uh,
I'm so fucking psyched.
Of course there's a few little doodads we've got to do.
Nia once an elliptical in there,
you know,
which is fucking hilarious to me because she could give a rats fucking ass about
this gym.
And still until it started coming together and now she loves it,
you know?
But what's great is it's the garage and everybody knows that the woman,
the wife,
the fucking,
the fucking lady over there,
everybody knows that they get the house,
but the guy gets the garage and see the women think that they win because they
got the fucking house.
Right.
You don't want the house.
The house is where all the responsibility is.
The house is where the bills come to the houses where the fucking people knock
on the door and the cops come.
They go to the fucking house.
Nobody,
nobody goes to the garage.
The garage is fucking,
it's,
it's genius.
You know,
you act like it's a shit hole,
blah.
And we'd go up to the garage.
They're like,
yeah,
yeah.
Get out of the house.
They don't give a fuck.
You go into the garage at that said,
yeah,
she's getting no fucking idea.
You wait till I,
I,
I get one of those little fucking Kegger raters out there and be doing keg
stands as I do curls.
Right.
Taking in calories as I burn them off at the same time while getting shit faced.
It's this new exercise video that I'm going to be putting out,
you know,
I dunno what I would call it to get what you need.
Alliteration,
right.
Drunk dips or some shit like that.
Right.
Just to get people to buy it.
Alcoholic aerobics as too wordy too now to worry too.
Two syllables.
I Dunno what I'll brainstorm on it.
You know,
all you gotta do is just have a fucking headband on and people will buy the
video.
If you promise them you're going to help him out,
right?
You have a fucking headband on,
they spray a little fake sweat on you and then you know,
all you got to get as a couple of hotties behind you just smiling and shit,
right?
The very least somebody can jerk off to it,
The next thing you know,
they start flying off the fucking shelves.
And then what do you do yet?
You add onto the garage,
add on the garage.
I've told you guys forever my dream fucking house,
my dream house.
I don't even know what the house looks like.
I just know what the garage looks like.
The garage,
don't you say as my dad loved to say the garage Doe Isi would be a three car
garage,
right?
One for me,
one for her and the other for whatever.
My old fucking truck.
All right.
And then upstairs they all,
there'd be an upstairs.
The upstairs would have a gym.
It have a drum room and a fucking cigar bar slash fucking sports bar.
That's what it would be.
Okay.
One door in,
one door out,
maybe a fucking little ladder to go up onto the roof to buy you.
Right.
And that's,
I think if every fucking guy had that,
there's no fucking way.
You couldn't be a happily married man because he just could be in the house.
You got your kids running around.
Everybody's freaking the fuck out and he and I need a break.
I want to be fucking single,
you know,
without the whois.
I just want to fucking just sit a drink without you fucking people in my,
what's left of my hair.
That's where the upstairs comes in.
And then you just go up there.
You have a great time while you slowly kill yourself,
you know?
And then with every cigar you smoke and every drink you have and you know that
you're one close,
one step closer to death,
which is a great thing because it's a release,
you know?
I don't know.
It started off happy.
It got a little dark there towards you.
You wouldn't know that.
I'm a happily married man,
uh,
by saying all that stuff,
but I also am by nature,
I am a fucking loner.
And,
uh,
you know,
I,
I just,
you know,
I just need to get away from people every once in a while and,
um,
I'll do that would be the fucking shit.
You know,
I have a couple of cool fucking dogs.
Those dogs at fucking lay around and like the howl,
you know,
like a fucking bloodhound,
right.
Just sit there watching the game,
getting hammered,
you know,
soundproof walls.
You can't hit your family.
He just sitting in there every once in awhile.
You look over your,
your fucking bloodhound.
A rottie roughly what the dog would bark and join with you.
Yeah,
I'm,
yeah.
You fucking get it.
Right.
I hope you enjoyed that because that fantasy though,
man,
I,
that's it right there.
You know,
I don't know what it is.
Some people want the White House,
some people won a fucking Oscar.
And then some people just want,
we'd like to be able to get a Tan and have a two story fucking garage.
That's it.
You know?
Um,
I'm part of that third group,
part of the third group,
everybody.
So anyways,
um,
I fucking went down there,
used all that rogue fitness shit that I bought and like I said,
you know,
these guys are not paying me or anything like that.
They actually sent me those colorful weights.
Now I don't know what the fuck to do with them cause I have more weight than I
need.
So I got some standup shows coming up in the La area.
If you're building a fucking gym,
you know,
and um,
oh,
how do I get,
how do I make this a fair contest?
I don't fucking know.
You build in a gym and you listen to the podcast and you want some colorful
plates,
some weights.
Uh,
I got them cause I was going to take it over to play it again.
Sam's have played against sports,
whatever the fuck they are,
but they just so God damn and Celtic,
you know what I mean?
If you think that baldheaded cont on the,
uh,
the pawn shop show how we just fucking,
you go in there and a man,
he got a bar of gold and the guy's like,
yeah,
you know how much you want for this?
You're like,
well,
the market value is fucking whatever.
Fucking $1,200 an ounce.
Why don't you give me a,
give me a thousand and outs?
And he's like,
so what you really want for it?
But I were on a fucking smash it over.
You've got fuck yourself.
Like what a fucking business people coming in selling their old fucking hair
dryers.
You know their ass out,
right?
And you've got to fucking take as much out of their crack as you can.
I get it.
You know what?
It's a business.
I'm going to hotter than that guy.
God bless him.
God bless them.
All right,
so play it again.
Sports is the same fucking way.
You'll come in with something with the price tag still on it and they'll go,
yeah,
I'll give you like a dollar 50.
You know what I mean?
It's just like,
I mean,
they make Richard Rollins look like a saint.
these fucking guys bust you down so bad.
It's like whatever you're selling them.
It's like,
how about I give to you for free,
but I get to hit you over the head with it first.
How about that?
Don't give me any fucking money.
I'm about to just mush it.
Right.
And you're fucking,
I'm not doing that.
So I would rather give it to a podcast listener for free,
but I'm not shipping these fucking things.
Gets like,
uh,
I don't know what it is.
I think it's two 45 pound plates to 30 fives.
That fucking big and they're heavy.
That's all I know.
Um,
whenever they're free free weights.
So anyways,
um,
I went down there yesterday,
I did fucking chest and Tris.
Today I did the,
uh,
upper body stuff,
all the,
uh,
bodyweight shit.
Neither wanted the speed bag,
which I thought was a little fucking stupid.
You know what I mean?
I always hated the speed bag unless you really training for a fight,
you know what I mean?
Do to do the,
then you go to your fucking cubicle.
It always seems so,
it just seemed fucking disrespectful to people actually fight for a fucking
living.
Like the,
the level of respect that I have for people that do that for a fucking living.
Just the,
the,
the fucking courage it takes to do that.
Um,
but of course now it's up there and I'm down there.
What did that get?
That ball didn't dip abated,
but what it did,
data dump.
Look at that,
that fuck data,
that data that then I'm doing,
it popped back up,
up,
up.
So now of course,
now I'm going to get fucking obsessed with that shit.
I don't know where it's going to do for me.
I'm hoping it's going to bring my freckles out,
you know?
Um,
anyway,
speaking of fights,
did anybody watched UFC?
You're upstream by day,
not of the red corner.
Did anybody see the UFC one 68,
eight,
eight?
MMM.
Was basically,
I think the USA or the world versus Brazil.
And I think Brazil once again proved that they are raw.
You know,
if you want to fucking get into a fight slash B in the missionary position with
another person,
if you think you're coming out on top of it ain't happening.
They pretty much,
they pretty much dominated the fucking night.
But a,
except for this one guy,
and I'm not going to know the names and actually tweeted the guy,
I'm still not gonna remember his name.
He has a very fucking,
a unique name and it was fucking,
he's fighting this guy and this guy is making all these silly faces when he's
going and they're going like the Brazilian dude,
I guess he was a champion or he is a champion.
That's right.
He's a champion.
And then he fucking,
uh,
that Jesus Christ that was having a few,
when I was watching this,
he fucking,
he was fucking,
he was a champion and he was supposed to fight.
He got hurt.
So he wanted to make sure he's 100% so he's coming down,
he's making all these silly faces and shit.
And I just remember the announcers go and like look,
and I was like,
no biggest fighter.
He's had it for years and he's making faces.
The camera is not even nervous,
right.
All of this shit.
And then he comes to fucking white dude.
He fucking,
you know,
old Dudley do,
right?
He's got a police officer's haircut.
You like this guy could have been a state trooper and he's fucking comment down.
And I'm like,
all right,
well let's see what's going to go on here at the white dude seems to be in a
little better shape.
The Brazilian guy,
surprisingly for a champion as a little bit of a dad bought,
you know what I mean?
And a whatever.
They start going at it and uh,
you know,
white boys taking it a little bit,
he's given it bag,
he's taking it,
whatever.
Then all of a sudden the Brazilian guy starts just running at him and he fucking
each one and he get in any regroups.
He starts running man again and this fucking guy,
the white to what?
The fucking state trooper haircut and he's backing up and as he's backing up,
it gives them just a little fucking little right there,
Fred with the fucking a right hook.
Right?
Well,
backing up and this fucking guy just,
he just shut off this guy's hard drive.
He just fucking pip.
And the guy was just write down like a controlled implosion,
you know,
when they take down a fucking building and everybody for some reason can take
off work to go down and watch it,
you know,
that's what they wasted a sick day on.
Like,
Hey,
he's anyway,
I can breathe in that fucking,
uh,
what do you call that shit,
not asphalt.
Oh Christ,
what the fuck do you call?
That shit is best dose,
right?
They can breathe it in anyways.
He fucking just hit the guy.
I keep just caught him the right way.
I mean,
granted,
if he hit me with that,
I mean I would have been dead.
There'd be no podcast ever again,
you know?
Um,
but he just caught the guy,
I guess.
Right.
And the guy just went right,
like a ton of bricks.
He fucking went down and the fucking white dude just lost it.
You know,
he just fucking,
who runs over to his corner climbs,
I thought was going to get on the fence.
He went right up and over,
hugged his halting and just kept screaming,
I'm a fucking world champion.
It was awesome.
Oh,
sorry.
Just blow out years here.
It was fucking awesome.
Do I get this too?
I think it's blue on my fucking ears.
It was just fun to see somebody like dad excited.
And uh,
then of course they said that he was from Cleveland.
So I tweeted out Cleveland finally want to champion championship and a,
that's why I think that's what I tweeted out or something like that.
But,
um,
congratulations to that guy who I can put,
I don't not going to butcher his fucking name.
Um,
it was awesome to see him win a championship.
It's great for the city of Cleveland.
Right.
And even though it wasn't a team sport,
you know,
if you're in Cleveland,
you gotta be,
you won't be thinking this.
Cause you guys,
you know,
you've been beaten,
you've been beaten down by this sports gods for so long that you guys really,
uh,
you're afraid of having hope.
But I remember reading about Christopher Columbus when he came over to the,
the the Americas,
which he thought was,
I dunno,
India.
I don't know what the fuck you thought.
Um,
before he got to land,
there was a couple of branches before he got the land and he started either,
you know,
being nice to people are chopping off people's hands because they wouldn't give
them their gold fillings.
Uh,
depending on what movie you believe,
you know,
I always loved that new studies find,
it's like,
what,
where the fuck was this information was it was an on a cocktail napkin and
somebody finally looked at it.
Huh?
Did you find one of those scrolls?
Was it written by somebody?
Hey,
by the way,
this is what really happened.
And somebody just kept it for years and they just let the light go and go and go
and then fall.
Maybe,
maybe the people that that survived what he did,
they had this shit written down.
I Dunno,
I think I'm fucking way off track here.
Where the hell am I?
Oh yes.
So anyways,
he's either way before he fucking got to land and he,
that was a halfway decent guy or an absolute fucking war criminal depending on
what you believe.
Either way.
Don't you get the day off?
You know,
sometimes people got to die to get a fucking day off.
when you really think about it.
Um,
anyways,
the fuck was I talking about?
Yeah.
You see some fucking branches and shit.
So there you go.
But guy from Cleveland is a champion.
All right.
It starts with once and now you gotta be looking at the Cavaliers.
I don't think they've lost yet.
You know,
it's funny.
Everybody in Cleveland right now is going shot.
All right,
I'll shut up.
Just say it.
Um,
that's another weird city.
Part of me wants Cleveland to win,
but there's just such a hilarious misery to the Cleveland Sports Fan.
I almost want to see it keep going.
So I guess I'm going to be happy either way.
I was really surprised at,
okay.
See,
beat a beat.
The Spurs.
Um,
considering I never watched,
I just watched the Celtics,
but I was hoping that,
um,
I was hoping that,
uh,
Tim Duncan was going to get his sixth ring,
you know,
just so I'd have yet another thing to say to fucking Laker fans when they bring
up Koby Bryant.
Well,
another guy during kobies time,
he was six.
He was a team player.
That one,
he really got everybody involved.
Uh,
did need fucking 90 million free agents to come in and help him out every
fucking year.
All right.
Sorry.
Anyway,
so let's plow ahead here.
Um,
what am I talking about here?
So,
yeah,
so congratulations.
And um,
I was disappointed with the Cyborg fight,
you know what I mean?
I would sit in there going like,
yeah,
I know.
I want to see this shit fight.
I want to see the,
you know,
and you know,
I got to tell you,
the women's fights are usually better than the men's.
I don't know why they go out,
like they go in and like fucking alley cats.
It's crazy.
Um,
I just don't understand how they can just hire,
you can just kick somebody in with the barefoot and it doesn't hurt you too.
You know,
they should fucking have just regular people like me just go in and do MMA shit
to each other and just watch this both crumble after the first strike punched
once with your hand.
Ha Fuck.
You know,
you put in under your,
um,
anyways,
but she fought some chick.
She was like eight,
six,
and one.
So I'm like,
what the fuck?
She's going to destroy it.
This is going to be over in the first round.
And then Lo and behold,
Jesus,
she fucking hits hard.
She fucking was just rain and punches.
And the other woman was,
was,
you know,
still pool's getting hurt was still way better than I would have one jab and I
would've been on my back,
but she was fucking eating them for well for a minute.
And then she went down.
And then there was a moment when she was always moving,
but it looked like she was out and the guy stopped the fight.
Right.
Which he shut it.
I think it was right to stop the fight.
So in the end,
when they have the official decision,
they cut to her right now and everybody cheers,
gs Brazilian.
It's a hometown crowd.
And when they cut to the other,
the woman who lost sheets like holding back tears and she's just looking up,
this is why I love this fight.
Or forever.
She was just looking up at the fucking,
the diamond vision thing,
whatever the big screen.
And she waited,
she,
she was on the scoreboard and the second she was on the scoreboard,
she just goes,
I've never fucking tat tat
and the whole place Buddha.
Okay.
She was so fucking mad.
Um,
which is understandable.
I mean,
I can't imagine train in that fucking long and that God damn hard.
And then it's just over in like three minutes.
Um,
it must have been brutal,
but um,
I dunno.
She was great.
She was all hard.
So hopefully she'll come back or what have I done?
I was really into that last one and I,
that Cleveland Guy was hilarious.
He was,
he was talking to every,
he was like,
you know,
and I know everybody here,
you don't like me because we're in Brazil,
but you guys make the sport great.
You called them out on it.
You know,
you're not voting for me cause I'm a fucking
cause I'm from Cleveland.
He should have been,
but I'm from Cleveland.
I'm used to this.
Um,
anyways,
let's see here.
I don't know if I have any advertising here.
Um,
hang on one second.
In the meantime,
I'll tell you a quick story.
You guys are all well aware that the,
uh,
the genius prince died.
Did you guys see that?
Do you get that and your papers just anyways,
out here in Beverly Hills,
they're having an auction on one of his guitars.
So yellow one that he did.
How many fucking times I got to type in my fucking password.
Come on.
Uh,
maybe cause I can't fucking remember it like that.
Fucked it up again.
Third Time's a charm,
huh?
Hmm.
I have to hum what it is or I fuck it up.
You imagine being this dumb and actually fucking having your own gym.
It's kind of dangerous,
isn't it?
All right.
So e
they're actioning off one of his guitars.
It was the one that he used with the,
the new power generation,
the cream album,
I believe.
And somebody bought it a few years ago.
I can't believe it was even for sale,
but some guitar collector admittedly doesn't play him.
He just collect some,
he paid 30 grand for this fucking thing.
So he says,
I should read this word for fucking word.
This is so fucking priceless.
And he says like,
the reason why he's selling it is because,
you know,
it's become,
with the passing of prince,
it's become so valuable.
Um,
daddy's actually nervous to have it.
He's nervous to own the fucking thing,
right?
Which
fucking,
it's,
it's like,
dude,
why don't you just say,
you know what?
The Guy fucking just died.
Everybody's paying attention.
This is a great time to sell this fucking guitar.
I'm trying to make money off of this guy's death.
Um,
but can't you just say that?
You know,
I hear it.
Is Prince's guitar?
All right,
I got to read what this guy said.
It's just so,
well,
there's nothing wrong with it.
You want to make a buck just,
you know,
the guy died and I'm trying to make fucking money off of it.
All right.
Um,
but blah,
yellow
face goes.
I've been a prince fan since I was a little kid and that guitar always stuck out
to me because it was super cool and stylish.
Said the current owner,
we paid about 30 grand for it.
He said,
unfortunately,
as morbid as it is,
when people pass,
their items become more valuable.
I think something is valuable as this could be too risky to continue to have in
my possession.
He's worried about his safety.
Get the fuck out of him and you try to make some money trying to make,
give me,
you're trying to make some money.
Okay.
That's so fucking creepy.
It's a really cool looking guitar,
but I don't think I could own a guitar of,
of a dead person who was way better at playing than I'll ever be.
Um,
I feel like that should be in like the rock and roll hall of fame so people
could just go in and look at it.
Stay in your house.
How fucking weird would that be?
Just having people over and people going.
Is that,
is it?
Yeah,
that's Prince's guitar.
I would immediately be whispering to my wife going,
this guy fucking killed.
Let's get outta here.
Fuck.
Does he have his guitar?
It would immediately create me up,
but that's me.
You know,
I'm paranoid son of a bitch.
He wants a fucking two story garage.
So me,
do I not have any fucking reads this week?
I think I might have advertisers that,
I don't know if you guys have noticed,
but I have slowly but surely pissed all of them off.
Um,
no.
Well,
well maybe.
Maybe I do have some advertising.
He just hasn't sent it.
Nope.
I'm hitting the refresh button.
I don't fucking see it now.
You know what,
why are they so sense it don't,
they understand that if I shit on it,
you guys actually listen to it and then maybe you'll buy it as opposed to just
fast forwarding through all of it.
That's what I try to do.
I mean,
I'm just,
you know,
I'm trying to help them make money right now.
What the fuck are you going to do?
Well,
speaking of,
you know,
I played for about five,
six years and then I stopped over the last couple of years when the downstairs
was being redone and then I recently got back into it.
But,
you know,
this is the deal.
I play drums,
I fuck around and guitar and um,
I've always wanted one of those lemon burst fucking,
uh,
Les Pauls.
I'm trying to find one,
a lefthanded one.
I just think it's fucking,
I dunno,
but you know what kills me whenever I get to get a guitar,
it was associate Les Paul.
I just start thinking of all the fucking great music I've,
yeah,
I've heard coming out of that thing and then when I pick it up,
it's just like,
oh Jesus.
Am I the asshole that just bought a fucking guitar he doesn't deserve.
I think I am.
All right,
I'm going to pause here just if so I could just fucking,
if I get advertising later,
I could just put it in here.
Um,
oh,
maybe not.
So maybe if dealt,
see,
let's see what happens.
All right.
Pausing here for some advertising that might be read later.
All right,
I'm back.
Did I read anything?
I Dunno.
I guess I'll find out later.
Anyway,
so,
um,
it's only for 27 here,
Pacific coast time and in 33 minutes,
the blues,
San Jose Shacks,
fucking,
um,
game starts.
And um,
I can't tell you how fucking excited I am about this and I already know how
they're probably going to sell this game.
That's a tale of two cities,
two cities that I've never gotten over the hump there.
Fans of add more heartbreak then a fucking blade blown up fucking spirit through
the chest.
But one thing's for sure for one city,
they'll be moving on to the Stanley Cup final,
not final.
So as I always say,
the Stanley Cup final.
And for you,
the other team,
more misery.
Well,
neither one should be ashamed.
Lave both knocked off between the toile humble to perennial giants in the west
with the La cakes and they'll fucking Chicago Black Hawks,
right?
They're going to do some shit like that.
Somebody is going to make it to the Stanley Cup final.
I hate that.
It's the final,
I like the finals and I hate when people go,
Ooh,
there's only walleyball is all we want,
but there's seven games.
So finals.
Right.
I'd have no problem with that plural.
That's a great thing.
You know when people go like,
yeah,
all those countries over there in Europe or around the world go,
why do you call it foot?
Yeah.
You know,
ours makes sense.
It's football and somebody goes,
right?
If you want to be technical,
you should call it feet ball.
You use in both your feet.
What do you call it?
Football.
There you'd go.
You'd trouble right back and forth between your feet so much called football,
Fidi Ball,
footsie,
which called footsie.
In other words,
why don't you go fuck yourself.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I am really excited about this and,
um,
what I would like to do,
don't you see is I would like to have,
uh,
what am I giant ice cubes with some fucking booze in it cause I booze hard on
the weekends cause I fucking stare at a God damn script all week before I come
home and booze heart,
who's getting to my drinking is out of control.
Um,
I think this is why people have children at some point in their life because if
you don't,
you just drink yourself to death.
I'll tell you it's fun.
It's a lot funnier than shit diapers.
Um,
anyways,
I am,
uh,
I'm nervous about this one.
I'm nervous.
I had a belief that the blues were going to get by the Black Hawks.
I'm not kidding.
I'm much surprise.
And uh,
I had a belief that they could get by the,
uh,
the Dallas Stars and certainly what the goaltending issues,
which I didn't even know they fucking ad.
Um,
there's still went seven.
So I figured this when it makes sense that you get to the next,
each tie,
you get a little blood tested.
So I want to say whoever wins this is going to fucking win the Stanley Cup in
the Stanley Cup,
Stanley Cup final.
Um,
but I was hanging out with Bart Nick last night and he knows more about hockey
than I know about myself.
And he was saying that,
uh,
he thinks Tampa Bay lightning know even though their goaltender went down.
So we shall see.
Um,
I'm sticking with the blues.
Me.
Well,
we low me,
meet me at the fair,
I'm sticking with the blues,
that's my team.
And um,
cause my real team,
the Bruins didn't make it,
but I still love him.
I'm going to be there again in October and if they play the blues,
I'm not going to give a fuck if they beat him fucking whatever,
12 to nothing.
I won't give a shit.
Um,
speaking of which,
somebody sent me something about,
um,
you know,
people always love to make points on all the dumb shit that I say on Twitter.
Like,
I mean,
how many times do I have to admit that I'm a fucking moron?
You really don't need to correct me.
I realize that I'm an idiot,
but somebody goes dictate.
It's not a lot of scoring and soccer and sends me like one day's worth of
fucking scores.
It's just like,
okay,
well if you average it out,
I think I'm right.
You know,
you know what's funny about that fucking Leicester City Championship?
Do you now they found out that they won a championship cause to other teams
played to like a one one tie.
There wasn't even a play off play off.
There wasn't even a fucking play off.
Like here we go,
this is it.
We're down to the final two fucking teams.
We're going to play for 19 hours and hopefully at some point somebody's going to
put the fucking ball and then in the net and the goal,
whatever,
and then it's going to be over.
Except it's going to be injury time that nobody knows what it is except for the
fucking,
uh,
they'll refs and everybody starts whistling.
I didn't even have that.
They watched these two other teams play to with Tai and then everybody went
crazy.
That seems really anticlimactic to me.
I had to think he wants somebody to fucking kick the ball.
It goes into the fucking somebody scores.
Right.
And then collectively as sports fans,
you all fucking bust your nut.
No,
Haha.
I,
it goes in
a bunch of people walking around and scarves,
watching somebody with win,
get a fucking tie and then you're excited about that.
And I,
I don't,
I,
I don't get that.
You know,
you would think that a country that survived the fucking blitzkrieg like that
level of excitement in your fucking life,
you think
you'd think use sports would,
would reflect it.
Maybe he hadn't.
Maybe you have fucking grandparents had enough fucking excitement for one
lifetime,
annual lifetime too.
So they just started watching that.
I don't know.
Well,
maybe I don't understand enough about the game and I'm just a fucking moron.
Maybe that's what it is.
And I don't know.
I have no idea what ever.
Go,
go get some fucking fish and chips and go fuck yourself.
All right,
let's,
let's read some,
um,
uh,
some of this bullshit here,
but I got from this week,
oh,
by the way,
I had a great weekend down and before I get to this,
I got an hour to fill,
so don't worry about it.
Um,
I had a great weekend and I,
I've just been in a real slump as far as writing new bits just because,
uh,
my life has ground to a halt here.
It's like,
you know,
I'm not going out.
I'm not doing anything.
It's like my wife went to the Beyonce concert last night at,
uh,
at the rose bowl and I was actually thinking I should have gone because there's
no fucking way.
I wouldn't have got a bit out of that.
I would have felt old.
It would've felt stupid.
I wouldn't know what the songs,
when she come out fucking whipping or weave around and shit.
That'd be something I could talk about.
Right.
Um,
but instead I went down to the comedy store and it did a couple of shows and,
um,
I actually went out,
let's have a comedians that are out there.
And I was just so fucking sick of doing the same shit and trying to make it
work.
I just,
every once in a while,
if you just go out there,
yeah.
And,
uh,
you're just not thinking anything and he just started fucking talking.
It works way better and it breathes new life into all your jokes.
I just kind of went out there and,
um,
which is a very terrifying thing to do when you,
if you've never done that in standup because you really feel like you're,
uh,
you know,
do you remember in like the Matrix when Keanu Reeves,
the trying to convince him to fucking step off that building and he's not going
to fall to his death,
all he has to do is bully isn't it?
Was At that movie,
it was a fucking Battlestar Galactica.
Moonraker I don't know what the phone in those space movies,
right.
It wasn't even space but Scifi.
Okay.
Um,
he had to like,
believe it and if you believe it,
then you find if you,
if you don't believe it,
you actually fall to your death.
This is sort of one of those things,
but of course you're not going to die.
You just going to,
you know,
metaphorically die on stage is his basic stepping.
Oh,
off the building is basically just leaving your act behind and just fucking just
talking.
So I just went out there and I just started riffing on fact that I made a smart
move by not going to be on say,
because,
you know,
when I went to Lady Gaga with my wife,
mmm.
You know,
I fucking,
I mean she was mad at me for like three fucking days after that one in defense
of me,
which there really,
really is no defense.
I watched the Patriots,
we lost I think to the ravens and the playoffs during the day.
So I was already drinking.
I already had that good six pack in me.
And then,
uh,
we took a car service to fucking lady Gaga and we went on the thing and it was,
it's,
you know,
I'm all about seeing the band.
I want to see the drummer and all that type of shit.
And she on this tour for whatever reason,
it's hard towards her choice,
whatever.
She had them in.
Like this house,
there was a fucking house and I couldn't see the drummer.
There was like a window.
I could kind of see his hands a little bit,
a little bit of his head.
And that was it.
And it was just like,
what the fuck?
I want to see the band.
And um,
I can't,
it was so long ago.
I mean,
what the fuck?
But I just started telling that story and how I fucking pissed her off.
And then if I went to the Beyonce thing,
you know how I would,
I would just,
you know,
when they sang like that independent woman song and everything,
just a dirty looks,
I'd be given most of the women there and no one that they were full of shit and
that they shouldn't be putting their hands up in the air.
You know,
it was just a smart move that I didn't go.
And my wife still has never gotten over my behavior at the lady Gaga concert to
the point that I actually asked her to come on the podcast to talk about the
Beyonce concert.
And she just goes,
no.
And I tried not to laugh.
I tried to hold it together and I go,
what do you mean though?
She goes,
we think I'm a fucking idiot now.
I'm not going on the podcast and give you,
giving you a,
an opportunity to start trashing beyond sake.
I'm not going to trash Beyonce.
Okay.
I have to admit,
she started showing me
video clips of the concert and she had it like the way she was holding,
she was,
we were on the couch and she snuggled up next to me.
So she's holding the kind of low to my,
you know,
near my stomach.
And like three times I started laughing,
looking at the,
uh,
yeah,
looking at the clips.
Um,
and look,
dude,
I know she's way more talented than I could ever be out and I don't even
remotely put it on a Shiller care,
but it's just something funny to me about when everybody dances in unison and
they have that,
you know,
that angry look on their face.
It's just the funniest assist.
Like what is your,
what is the problem
coming up?
And they got their arms out,
you know,
and they're doing that little fucking thing with their head and their feet are
running.
Uh,
it's just,
I can't,
I can't even dance like the fucking nerve of me to laugh at it.
But it always strikes
is just,
it's,
it's absolutely ridiculous.
Something,
it's,
I understand why it's awesome and people appreciate it,
but it's also really fucking funny to me.
I should say.
I don't know why.
Maybe I get one,
I'm just a cut.
Don't listen to me,
so whatever.
So I made a great fucking move by not going to that concert.
Made a very smart,
married a couple of years getting a wise in my old,
I just was just like,
you know what?
I can,
that's,
that's the best.
When you start,
you start to know somebody and yourself well enough to be like,
you know what?
I see the fight coming.
You know what I mean?
It's actually,
it's like slipping punches,
which I,
there's something else,
another reason why I suck at fighting escape.
You could literally tell me on Thursday,
I'm throwing this punch at this time and you would still not only catch me with
it,
you like the feel whole hand or foot or whatever.
I just can't do it.
I,
you know,
whatever,
I stink at it.
So,
um,
I saw this fight coming and I was just like,
I was like,
all right,
no.
And I gave my,
you know,
my ticket away and she took one of her girlfriends.
So I look good with the friends and all of that fucking shit.
And I avoided a major fucking fight and I just went on stage cause I was like,
I'm sick of my jokes.
That was the point of this shit.
So whenever I get into this,
these,
um,
whatever you call it,
writer's block,
even though I don't write whatever,
just riffing block,
I guess cause I just sort of wing my shit.
Um,
yeah.
I just say to myself,
what am I thinking right now?
What am I feeling?
And I was feeling,
thank God I didn't go to Beyonce because me and my wife would get into a big
fight.
So,
and you know,
it's funny,
I didn't even make that decision.
I kind of as I was don my rare brought me up.
Yeah.
He gives the best fucking intros.
He said,
this fucking enjoy goes,
you know,
it's next guy coming to the stage.
Uh,
you know,
he never made me laugh.
You know,
immediately people would just die.
They just fucking,
he just does that stuff.
But,
you know,
people seem to enjoy him.
Um,
I dunno.
I've written a lot of his stuff and just,
you know,
just making me look like a complete asshole.
So I went out there and it wasn't until after I shook his hand that I was
actually thinking of the first bit I was going to do and I was just like,
Oh God,
I can't,
it's physically going to feel like shit coming out of her mouth.
I can't even say it.
And then I just,
over the years of just knowing that trick,
I was just like,
what am I feeling right now?
It's just I'm feeling,
I'm glad I fucking did go to Beyonce because I get new a three day fight with my
wife and I just started talking about that and it just,
it worked.
And then I had this other chunk of material and I did the last joke without even
setting it up from the other shit.
And it's still worth it.
We just worked in a different way.
And um,
it was,
it was great.
It may be fucking love standup again cause I was really,
no guy would ever hate standup but just this whole fucking writing every day.
All right.
Now see the magic of technology is now
10 oh one Pacific coast time.
And I'm watching the third period of a Saint Louis,
San Jose.
Um,
I take the fucking game.
What's the first two periods?
One St Louis so far.
All right.
Let's see.
Have you spoken as,
get on with the fucking sports here.
All right.
Uh,
you need to know how to cook when she got a broad your license.
She's old school.
She know what I mean.
Not only do you feel like you know your way around the kitchen,
but cooking at home,
eating healthier and saving money instead of ordering expensive takeout all over
again.
But where do you start?
Blue Apron as you covered?
Fuck for the last 10 or less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron delivers all the fresh ingredients and you need to create a home
cooked meal.
Just follow the easy step by step instruction.
He's me of actually look really good.
Uh,
we,
this was around when I was a single seller.
Uh,
each meal can be prepared in 40 minutes or less.
No overwhelming trips to the grocery store,
no more sad takeout.
And that a how dietary preferences,
no matter your dietary preferences,
Blue Apron,
Nix.
It a bleed and prepared dishes like salmon with asparagus and new potato Hash
and me Aov right in your own kitchen.
I don't even know what happened.
That is,
what's up.
Fuck is they only
cook with the ingredients that you've never used before.
Like watermelon,
radishes,
Pharaoh,
modal and purple potatoes and recipes are between 500 to 700 calories per
portion.
Delicious and good for you right now.
You could get your first two meal for free.
Yes,
we wait for dotcom slash for that blue apron,
blue apron.com/ [inaudible] a better way to cook.
Oh,
here we go.
Me On de Leon d no more sweaty balls to do.
Me On d and B's.
I'm drinking them.
Maker's mark towards down the fund.
Off My fucking underwear dries up real quick and I don't care my ball good bronc
in.
So am I by the fucking 10 your queen is all right here.
Whether you're wearing a suit or
whether you're wearing a suit or
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your underwear unless you Matthew mcconaughey
and then you're wearing that.
She is running down the beach carrying a couple of hard whenever the fuck it is
he does on TV.
That's a magazine anyway.
But instead of making a statement like trouper man,
everyday clothes,
your underwear is probably boring.
The undies is here to change that.
Well you know what she,
what it has on the way,
it's pretty boring as it is.
Just read know so you know this fucking name on it.
That's when it gets interesting.
Um,
please include all the volume point.
Why would not eroded?
I'm going to read it.
Modal is pronounced modal.
Every pair of me undies is made from sustainable mode out of dress fabric twice
as soft as cotton,
allegedly nothing can describe the fit and the feel of me undies.
He got to feel it up against you,
evolved to appreciate it.
But once you fire him on your understand why they're called the world's most
comfortable underwear.
And if you know a lot of your first fairly on the east,
no questions asked me and he says dozens of styles and limited edition prints to
help you make a statement with your underwear.
Where there anyone can see them or not.
Remember Superman.
Um,
uh,
they're really great marketing and spoke towards the comic con Crowder.
Give a fuck about superman.
Didn't he lose the Batman?
A shipping is free and you went and Canada and can you can save up to $8.
Prepare with me on these subscription plan and get the subscription or a single
pair get pointed done off your first order.
When you go to me and Andy Saw [inaudible] rash burn for 20% off your first
order.
And then here we go.
The final one,
legal five things you can count on when using legal zoom for your business.
Number one,
more than a million people have already trusted legal zoom to stop,
start the business and corporations LLC,
nonprofits,
Dva,
whatever the fuck those are and more use legal zoom to get started the right
way.
Uh,
number two,
the Duke experience,
you can put on needles zone for all that you can count on Eagle Hill for all the
details.
They helps.
Uh,
they've been helping all types of businesses,
owners for over 15 years.
Number two,
walk numeral chase,
helpful support.
They have the right people standing by ready to help you with your questions.
All based in the United States.
Oh,
shots fired India,
a number of,
um,
legal advice.
Legal isn't a lot fun.
So they built the network of independent attorneys available in 48 states.
You get answers to your legal questions and they can reduce supplier concepts,
employment laws,
and help with most of the day to day situations that pop up.
And finally,
letter be e,
g,
C,
d,
e.
That's the first one,
single,
uh,
you know,
I learned how to count to 10 in Spanish.
Dot.
Boston
get knocked down.
They always go
like,
you're going to get the fuck up or what I call the actual make the smart choice
for your business and legal zoom.com today.
And don't forget to enter@checkouttosaveevenmorelegalzoom.com.
All right,
that's it.
Back to the park chest.
You sons of bitches.
Let's get to some questions here for this week.
Oh,
um,
speaking of which,
how great his song,
his top Jimmy.
I fucking love that song.
All right,
so I Annika.
Hey,
Bill,
love your podcast.
I want him to tell you about my sister's cure for s a Sayada ACOG lie but don't
worst.
Okay.
Cloud,
um,
providence say chat and I one night only shy
my ass fucking
um,
she suffered from Sciatica for years.
For years.
Her doctor recommended she see a podiatrist.
That's a foot doctor for all you civilians out there who filmed her from behind
fucking creep as she walked on a treadmill.
Yeah.
What are these yoga pants,
by the way?
I don't understand why guys are fucking so obsessed with yoga pants.
I've never been yoga pants or like just,
you know what?
I took too many yoga classes.
I just know what the room smells like and I just feel like that's what you clamp
smells like when you wear those.
And I know that's immature.
I'm sorry.
Um,
he immediately saw her right foot was rolling out is she walked,
he said this was causing her problems with Sciatica and he made custom orthotics
shoes,
inserts that she wears most of the time.
She said this worked immediately to completely eliminate her pain from Sadeka.
Ooh,
she said,
after you start wearing the orthotics,
you should visit a chiropractor to get everything back in alignment and you're
good to go.
Give it a try and go fuck yourself.
Thank you so much for that.
Um,
I don't think I have that issue,
but I got the name of a good chiropractor and you know what,
God dammit when I'm uploading this podcast,
I'm actually going to go see a doctor because somebody sent me this thing on,
um,
on Twitter.
Go Bill,
go see a doctor.
Jesus did we learn nothing from so and so.
And it was somebody who was on Letterman who was,
she had a shortness of breath and he kept blowing it off.
He kept talking to people who weren't doctors and they're like,
I'm sure you're fine.
I'm sure you find.
Then he found out it was fucking lung cancer.
Obviously that's not what I'm looking at here.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
so I will definitely go.
Oh,
thank you for that.
All right,
number two,
uh,
Duke
where we'll Katelyn take his shit this week.
Um,
number two.
Hi Bill.
I was a wall and floor Tyler for 27 years and my go to for any lower back pain
was a gel ice pack in lying on a hard floor.
The Gel pack molds to the area that is sore and the hard floor keeps you spine
flat.
Lie on your back.
Wait,
lie on your back on the floor with your knees bent.
Put the ice.
No.
What does that mean?
They bend and then lift them up or just to have the feet on the floor.
Um,
can you put your foot down on the two?
Get jump up on the one.
Sorry.
Thinking about prince now.
All right.
Um,
then we'll the ice pack and then try it.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
I missed the whole fucking thing.
It lie on your back,
right?
You know what it is?
He wrote a bunch of words that are all like the same.
I have some sort of fucking dyslexia because he has lie like a bunch of times
and feet lie on your back on the floor with your knees bent.
Put the ice pack at the spot,
giving you trouble.
Leave it there.
Oh,
I know why he didn't have any punctuation.
Leave it there for 15 minutes.
You can watch TV doing this then moves the ice pack and then try to feel like
you are pressing your spine into the floor.
Continue with the treatment once or twice a day until you feel better.
I hope this works for you.
I loved F is for family and reminded me of my childhood and I'm a 57 year old
Australian male.
Love the specials and the podcast.
Hope you get better soon.
Well that's good to know.
So you're 10 years older than me.
Well that should work because we kind of age bill a little bit older than I than
I was in 1973 or 74 he's about 11 years old and which would mean he would have
been,
would have been born in 62 so that's right in your wheelhouse,
right?
You probably be born and like what,
58 59 yeah,
built.
That's how the math works out.
All right,
cool.
Um,
okay.
Australia mailable for,
thank you so much for watching and please tell more people down there in
Australia.
If you can to check it out.
Um,
I actually heard a lot of times people say to put heat on your back ice,
I guess is better.
Uh,
cause it,
if you have any sort of,
uh,
inflammation in the nerve or something like that.
I Dunno.
I've been using a leaf and doing these stretches,
I feel much better.
And I haven't been sitting down at all.
I've actually been squatting like a Vietnamese gambler and,
um,
I don't know.
I,
uh,
that's been working for me in these stretches.
I still haven't quite
gotten it better,
but I'm going to walk,
go to a chiropractor and get adjusted out Jesus.
And you know what?
I that,
and I also need glasses finally giving into that because my,
um,
every two years when you're at my advanced age,
you got to go get a physical,
physical.
I want to get physical.
Um,
I got my pilot's license.
So you got to every,
you know,
if you're a younger fella,
every floor lady lady,
every five years you,
you,
you got to renew your medical,
um,
you gotta get it updated.
So with me,
it's every two fucking years and I barely made it through.
And I'm literally like,
what the fuck am I doing here?
I don't want to wear glasses,
just don't,
I just don't want to have another fucking thing that I have to deal with.
And I also have this paranoia that all glasses do is make you fucking eyes
worse.
Kind of like a chap stick.
It just dries out your lips even more.
That's like the big urban myth.
And then you get addicted to it,
then he got to use it.
You know,
whenever I have dry ass lips,
I just use a little Vaseline works like a fucking charm and then I just started
pounding waters and then you're fine.
You fucking fine that fucking chapstick and all that shit.
I don't like it and don't like it makes me have weird dreams,
you know,
get that chemical in there and seeps right in the fucking face and it goes right
to your brain.
And next thing you know,
you're just running around with an ax and your drinks.
You have to have a dream like that.
So raise a year screaming,
answer me.
Uh,
I'm just making this shit up.
People out.
I don't know what the fuck you want from me.
Usually the,
the advertising takes up a little bit of time and I,
and I don't have any full 48 another 12 minutes and then the game stats.
Oh,
and I got another 15 minutes here.
Fuck.
Well thank you.
Thank God for Tivo,
right?
All right.
Grass killin name.
Alright.
A fantasy,
revenge advice.
Hello billion.
I'm a 23 year old male.
I live with my parents in the country that even Australia makes.
Oh Wow.
They even Australia makes fun of two from a Australians here.
Oh,
New Zealand.
Oh Jesus.
I live with my parents in a country that even Australia make fun of New Zealand.
I thought he meant a part of a country.
I can't read people.
I love emphasis for family and can't wait for season two.
Thank you so much.
Please tell more people in New Zealand about it if you haven't already,
if he got the time.
I'm not trying to put you out.
If you don't want to be that Douche,
don't be the Douche.
But if you do,
I'd,
I'd appreciate it.
All right,
so here we go.
Fantasy,
revenge advice.
Sometime ago my father was using a lawn trimmer on the right side of the front
yard,
which is only a few feet from our neighbor's driveway while trimming the edges
of small rock in the grass shutout and hit our neighbors parked car in the
driveway.
Our neighbor was already at the front of his house and either saw or heard the
bang and started yelling at my dad who was apologetic.
The rock the Rock,
put a small dent in the car,
which was hard to see even close up when I,
when I was told what happened,
my dad by my dad,
I was a little pissed that he yelled,
but I knew he had a right to be upset and although it was an accident,
my dad would happily pay for the damages because he knew he was at fault.
Um,
our neighbor didn't talk to us again about a bill or anything,
so we've quickly forgot about it and moved on.
A few weeks later,
I was at the front of our house and I saw that the right side of our lawn was
completely dead,
of foot inwards.
I realized this fucking cunt had poisoned the area of the grass that would
usually be cut using the trimmer.
Wow.
This guy's got major communication issues.
So this incident would never happen again to state my,
despite my dad telling him that he would only mold alon when the driveway was
empty in the future.
Um,
I asked my dad if he knew anything and he told me he had known for a few days
but didn't want to make a big deal about it.
My Dad is a very easy going guy who doesn't get bothered much myself on the
other hand,
spent the night,
uh,
the next few nights fantasizing about revenge.
Oh,
it looks like you take after your Ma.
All right.
Get Dad's easy going.
He married a fucking hot blooded woman and she's,
you know,
she calmed her down,
right?
And then you,
you,
you got her fucking DNA.
All right.
I like,
I like where this is going so far,
even though I'm not a big revenge guy.
You Dad's easygoing.
It's his house already.
My Gut saying your dad's easy going.
It's his fucking house,
you know?
Um,
yeah.
Don't do anything to disrupt it.
And you said it.
I thought about doing the exact same thing to his lawn,
but spelling out the word coward.
Oh my God.
That's fucking hilarious.
I thought about pulling out all of his plants and dumping it on his car to send
a message.
It's been a few months and I still get pissed off when I think about it,
but I decided not to stoop to his level and pull off a bitch move like that.
The only option would be to confront him,
but there is no scenario in which that would end.
Well,
why not?
Um,
Why can't you just next time you see him,
just say like,
dude,
I got to tell you something.
I haven't been on this planet for a long time,
so maybe I need to see more bitchy behavior,
but that's the biggest pussy bitch fucking way.
I don't do that.
It's going to cook.
I don't know.
I would just say,
hey,
you have any idea why this part of the lawn died?
Isn't that amazing?
And I would do that to them every fucking time.
Just do something to drive him nuts.
Anyways,
he goes,
I've decided to do nothing and moving on,
but it's been about a year and I'm still thinking about it.
What would you have done?
Am I justified to be pissed?
This pissed?
And how the fuck do I stop myself from letting it get me in such a bad mood
every time I walked past our front lawn and see the dead strip of launch?
Thanks for listening,
Bill.
Come back to New Zealand.
Um,
your lawn is still dead.
Look,
I'm not big on revenge,
but the great thing that you have right now is you've waited a year.
Um Hm.
So if you were to do anything,
obviously don't bring any physical harm to the person.
Um,
he does seem to love that car.
It's just why would you do it?
MMM.
Why don't you guys read,
just replant the fucking grass.
That's what I would do.
I would replant the grass.
This is what you do.
Replant the grass
and get all excited.
And then without him knowing what you do is you set up a fucking video camera,
all right?
And he just videotape and you,
you try to catch them doing it.
That's the best way to do it,
right?
And then he has to fucking pay for it and then pay for the previous thing.
The previous time he poisoned it.
Like that's what I would do.
You know what I mean?
There's obvious things that you could do.
You could go to a fucking auto zone and buy one of those little catch trays that
captures oil,
you know?
And then when the night you could undo his fucking
let all the oil out of his car on,
screwed the thing on the oil pan and you screw it back up.
And then he seizes the edge on his car.
You can go that route.
You know,
there's no oil in the fucking car.
Um,
the key is what you have to do is
okay,
he would still figure it out.
So you can,
you can't do this is all bitchy fucking moves.
You know what I mean?
You got to have a face to face thing.
Or what I would do is I would just repaint three,
plant the grass and I would set up a fucking video camera
and maybe just say that.
Just say,
hey,
just so you know,
if you plan on poison Eric Grass,
cause I know you're not a man and you would never say anything to my dad's on my
self's face.
You know,
just so you know,
I got this security,
you're going to be on video and we're going to catch you doing it.
Okay.
All right.
It costs us a lot of money and I,
I,
oh my God,
what a,
uh,
in a perfect world,
could you just go over and just fucking take,
just answers the door and you go hi.
And he is Buddha right in the nuts,
huh?
You would think they need just take a strip of the dead grass and you just start
fucking beating his back with it.
That's what the fuck you wanted.
Do I,
you know what?
I actually want to do that right now.
But you know what?
You can't do it.
You know what?
Fuck him.
He did it to you.
Oh Dude.
You know something.
I think you're,
I think what you came up with this the best.
Why don't you just write coward?
No.
Cause then he's going to do something else to your dad's house.
Oh,
this guy's a cunt.
You know what?
He doesn't have the balls to confront your dad.
So when I think you'd do yet do the little cow thing and then set up video
cameras and catch them doing something else,
but then you've done something to him.
See,
it's just,
it's just awful.
It's just as Bitchy,
tit for fucking tat thing.
I don't know what you have to do,
but I feel like something has to be said.
At least
I know what you do.
This is what you do.
You go down to a fucking lady shoe store,
all right?
And you buy a cheap pair of fucking women's shoes
and next time you see you wrap it up like a present.
And you just give a tool
and there's a card in there and everything,
and then you just,
this is what you do.
You do that.
You just humiliate the guy.
And he just open it up and just say,
hey sweetheart,
just want to get you,
you,
you just write from your heart about what a fucking bitchy is.
It just is what you do.
Don't ever don't curse in it at all.
Right?
It really nice and lovely.
Um,
but in that,
without ever cursing,
just let them know what an absolute fucking pussy he has for doing that bay.
You Go,
oh,
that's,
I,
I think that,
you know what?
I think that's a winner.
You know what?
I might have to,
I might have to outsource this to my listeners if you guys have better ideas of
what to do there.
Nobody gets hurt.
You made your point.
It's fucking hilarious.
And that's a funny,
you know,
you tell people that this guy did it and they go,
so what'd you do?
He tell him,
I went out,
I went to a lady's Tish,
she was doing,
I bought him a pair of pumps.
Okay.
And then you get to laugh and every time you see him just wave and just start
calling them sweetheart Kim,
a pet name.
Maybe you give him a woman's name like Diane or something.
Just,
hey,
Diane,
how'd you like the shoes?
And just every fucking day you can just do that forever.
I Dunno.
It made me feel better about the situation.
Maybe you can do that.
Who the fuck knows?
Anyways,
good luck with that.
Uh,
but don't do any physical harm or real property.
That's the brilliance.
I must said genius.
Pat Myself on the back there.
Sorry about that.
Um,
that's,
that's what I like about the last plant is that you're not hurting him.
You write it eloquently.
You're not cursing.
There's nothing he can really do.
You just bought him a gift that you'd give.
You'd give a woman,
it's perfect.
You know,
I'd send them to the candy on Valentine's Day.
Just,
Ah,
just torture the guy.
But you just keep giving them gifts,
you know?
I don't know what else,
what's some,
get them some flats.
Okay.
I Dunno.
Just a bunch of shit like that.
I don't know who the fuck knows.
Maybe you just do it once and then that's it.
And then what you do and then right after that you replant the grass and then
you just let them know that you know that he did it and he's going to be too
much of a bitch to try to do it again.
And then he can tell you dad years later that that's don't tell your dad that
you did it.
And then years later you're telling me you did it when you're having a pint and
you guys can fucking laugh your balls off.
All right.
Work argument.
Um,
hey bill,
I work with some real morons.
I'm in sales.
So everyone is a hotheaded tool.
Really.
I thought you guys were like funny.
It always seemed like the salesmen were always breaking balls and being funny.
Um,
they all think they're living in a sales movie.
Oh,
okay.
Too many Glengarry Glen Ross.
All right.
Uh,
we have set accounts and nothing about our job requires us to generate new
business from cold leads,
but that doesn't stop these tools.
So the other day they're bitching.
About Saturday night live and how it's not funny anymore.
That's not really a big deal.
People always bitch about SNL even when it's good.
That didn't bother me,
but then they all started saying how they'd be funnier on the shell.
No,
Jesus.
Here we go.
This is like maybe watch.
No,
I guess it's not like that.
All right,
let's continue.
I'll just say it's like me watching UFC being like,
oh,
you know what I wanted done.
Um,
so this is when I chimed in and told them that it's harder than it looks and
that they did not.
They did not.
They did have a shot.
What?
And that they did have a shot.
Oh,
the,
oh,
that if she left out a word there said it's harder than it looks.
And if they,
if they did have a shot at having no stage presence or Rick or experience,
they would end up freezing up.
Then they'd be the guy who froze up,
whose face was everywhere.
I made the point to them that if they were offered a spot on SNL,
they'd be better to turn it down.
They'd have a happier life if they said no to SNL.
Jesus,
do you agree with this?
And if you are offered SNL,
would you take it?
Um,
okay.
Two.
I think that the people on SNL are funnier than a salesman.
Yes,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
Do I think that they would freeze up now?
Not necessarily.
They would probably,
you know,
maybe a few would freeze up.
Others would get dry mouth and still plow through it.
Others would ham it up,
you know,
who knows.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno.
Um,
yeah,
their eye,
if they offered me SNL I would know that they were in a lot of trouble.
I am a 48 year old man next month.
I think that they like to try to get young talent and um,
I think that window has closed.
Um,
I haven't said that.
I got nothing but respect.
It seems like haven't just trying to write a fucking cartoon where we got all
the fucking time when the world to do this shit where they have to come out with
a brand new,
you know,
90 minutes minus fucking commercials.
Um,
what's that?
90 minus 24 to get technical eight minutes every half hour.
That's 64 fucking 66 minutes a week.
Fuck you.
There's no way I've or I've heard nothing,
but that's an absolute,
it takes a special personality to be able to do that well,
to handle that.
And um,
I would actually be worried about what it would do to my standup career,
having that level of a commitment.
Um,
which is why I prefer to do a role in a movie where it's just sort of like,
okay,
we got you from here to here.
So it's a finite thing with at SNL.
Shit is just like,
I don't know when they started,
when they stopped,
but it just seems to be a,
it's a hell of a commitment.
But,
um,
yeah,
so they go,
did I answer your question?
Um,
yeah.
I'll have to get offered SNL.
Who says fucking note of that?
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno if I get that on.
Why am I fucking stressing over this?
It's not happening.
But anyways,
thank you for sticking up for everybody on SNL.
I appreciate that.
All right.
Okay.
Here's the last one from a lady from a fucking lady,
a woman proposing Yo baby cakes.
Belieber uh,
just curious.
What are your thoughts?
What are your,
what?
Oh,
just curious what your thoughts are.
Sorry everybody,
I'm bad at this.
Just curious what your thoughts are on women proposing love you.
Thanks for advocating for pitfalls.
Hope to see you soon.
Please don't use my name while they never show me your name.
MMM.
I think that's a bad move on the woman's part.
Uh,
I think you guys generally speaking are more gung Ho to get married than guys
are.
And um,
if you propose to a guy and he's too much of a pussy to say no.
Okay.
Um,
and then you ended up marrying the wrong person.
I think as a woman you should wait for the fucking guidance.
I think there's a reason why the guy asks.
Yeah.
Uh,
it's because we don't want to do it.
So if we are actually asking,
then you know,
you with the na,
that one,
most of them ended up in divorce.
You know what?
I don't know.
MMM.
That could be maybe be kind of cool.
Okay.
There's something cute about it.
I can tell you that,
not talking down to you,
but,
uh,
I used to always fake proposed to Nia.
Now he's always go Nia,
I'm proposing to you right now.
And she would always be laughing,
knowing I was fucking around and I would always go,
I propose that we break up.
It was a silly joke and he used to always make her fucking laugh.
Um,
I dunno.
She was real cute during that time when she like wanted me to ask and uh,
My wife's fucking adorable.
So I mean,
what am I going to do?
MMM.
Took a special kind of fuck a woman to trick me into doing this.
Uh,
she didn't trick me.
Anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
I don't know if I have any advertising left anymore,
but who gives a fuck?
I never did it for that anyways.
Right.
I'll go out and go dance for my supper tonight.
You're advertising the water money,
although I loved it.
Oh,
I love that.
Advertising horror money.
Maybe I still have it.
Who knows?
That's the podcast.
Once again,
um,
I will try to take some video.
Uh,
this week I actually made a couple of ones,
but I made one for visy and I made one for fucking Dean del Rey,
so it's got their name on it.
Um,
when I say maybe I'll just post those fucking things.
I don't have to fucking move my truck out again.
Do it.
Anyways.
That's it.
That's a podcast for this week.
Thanks for listening.
Go fuck yourselves.
And I'll check on a Thursday.
Let's go blues.